foreign  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  themselves  so fat and satisfied  they can't imagine not someone like me  would ever get inside their house  Cassie and Elder  the Empire is choking us so slowly  we're starting not to notice  all I'm asking is this  wouldn't you rather give it all  something real  I need all the heroes I can get  for the greater good  call it what you will help let's call it  War  as fermenting out there so  pockets are fermenting  you're in my net  are you a fish why are you at these  you're slipping  I'm not slipping I've just been hiding  for too long  as long as ever  child film is what I'm really doing what  are you really doing  this is what Revolution looks like  I'm tired of losing  foreign  [Music]